c'est toujours leur de babar issa avec
bravo loto le jeu 100% gratuit qui peut
changer ta vie
téléchargez l'appli ajouté gris et tente
de remporter jusqu'à un million d'euros
sans rien faire bravo l'auto facile
d'être rick je vais pas répéter tout ce
qu'ils m'ont dit tous mes camarades moi
je voudrais déjà parlé beaucoup de
l'homme parce que voilà je vous ai
rencontrés il ya un an
enfin ya quelques mois et on entend
beaucoup de choses sur vous et votre
votre coeur est aussi grand que votre
folie et et je suis content de faire
partie de votre vie pour ce qui est du
vaincu matters adducteurs juste personne
n'a rappelé mais vous avez quand même
fait 2 millions de téléspectateurs ce
qui est énorme
sega a fait un million de l'équipe cyril
je voulais aussi juste avant qu'elle
donne votre note j'avais un petit cadeau
pour vous que je pense que ça va merci
ça fait plaisir la joie seuls ces
derniers
merci tout cas tu tires il a bien cassé
l'ambiance les milieux urbains des petit
extrait à regarder oui parce que vous
arrivez à nous faire rire avec tous ces
dingues et même juste quand vous rentrez
dans une chapelle au bras de mokhtar
donc toujours à vegas et voilà c'est du
dur et cyril hanouna quoi
[Musique]